this episode of the minimalists is
brought to you by
nobody because advertisements suck
non-minimalists
[Laughter]
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live
a meaningful life with less my name is
joshua fields milburn
ryan nicodemus is on vacation but fear
not
i'm here with non-profit ceo sheila
moravati
sheila thank you for being here today
thank you for having me this is great
well you know today you know we're going
to talk about
waste we're going to talk about all the
ways in which we
are wasteful i thought we'd start by
maybe you could talk to me about
habits of waste your organization yeah
so habits of waste was born
after i spearheaded the first plastic
straw and cutlery band in history which
was in the city of malibu
and it was really after a huge
organization i started initially called
the crayon collection
and people were so confused about why i
was doing straws and crayons that i said
okay i've got to start another charity
called habits of waste because it was
all-encompassing
my work really began through my
background in sociology and
understanding how
human behavior is you know kind of
malleable
in the masses i kept going to
restaurants with my daughter and
noticing every single table around me
would get crayons and they'd
get thrown in the garbage and i kept
wondering why are we doing this this is
such bizarre behavior where there's
so many kids who have none none at all
so
i started the crayon collection where i
asked restaurants to collect the crayons
kids
left behind as well as families who had
a ton of crayons at home and didn't know
what to do with them
and i would pair them with an
underserved title one or head start
school within five miles
so that they could benefit from the
crayons and then we started a whole art
education program by challenging artists
to create project ideas using just
crayons
so that was really the start of my whole
work
that led into habits of waste and then
it was in those restaurants that i saw
the plastic straws and wondered
no one asked for those we're just
getting you know there's an imposition
on us about stuff
coming our way and we didn't even ask
for it so i thought we had to do
something and the city of malibu to me
was the most iconic beach city in the
world so there you have it
yeah well so so by the way if you want
to learn more about the crayon
collection
it is crayon collection.org we'll put a
link to that in the show notes as well
and we're going to dive deeper into
habits of waste i do want to talk to you
about that but it's fascinating i worked
in a restaurant for
four or five years throughout high
school and and thereafter a little bit
and
i want washing dishes busting tables and
waiting tables but busting tables
especially i was responsible for
creating a lot of the waste now of
course i didn't even think about it at
the time either
this is just what we do we hand out
crayons often when they don't even ask
for them it's just like let's pacify
some people
of course we hand out plastic straws
this is dayton ohio in the 90s so
yeah it was plastic everything and and
styrofoam everything even
to go and and we just created all of
this waste but i didn't think about it
at all and i think maybe the message
that i want to talk about with you today
is maybe it's just a question to start
with why don't we even think about it
why do we take all of this for granted
and not realize what we're doing to the
rest of the world
i think there's there's a an element of
uh daily behaviors that get ingrained so
deeply and so deep rooted that they
become normal and i use normal lightly
because in my opinion there's really no
such thing as normal
right we create what normal is and so my
job is to highlight
what it is that we're doing wrong that's
normal now
and most of the time what's beautiful
about it is that people
believe strongly that the new ideas i
might have
are better and they're not you know even
opposed to it it's just a matter of
seeing it and then you can't unsee it
and that's when the change happens
i think normal has become unintentional
in many ways
when something is normalized we we just
we take it for granted we act as though
it's always been that way it's a
tradition even though it's lasted for
five ten fifty years it's not it's not
this uh
um cultural imperative that has lasted
throughout all of
humanity and yet because we grew up with
it we we just assume that it's always
supposed to be this way
we've got some questions here from our
audience i thought we'd go ahead and
dive into those
our first one is from rachel in st louis
missouri
sometimes i'm at odds with what to do
with the things that i want to get rid
of especially clothing
i have a hard time sometimes giving to
goodwill and salvation
army and places like that because i know
that
any of their surplus sometimes well
most likely ends up in other countries
and messes up with their own economies
and i wanted to know if you have any
suggestions for your listeners on where
they can
give their stuff to people in need if
there's
places that they can look for in their
own cities
and towns that would actually benefit
the people locally
instead of abroad so sheila this is a
fascinating question because
i think a lot of people deal with this
obviously you know they regret the stuff
they have now or maybe the stuff was
even useful for a period of time it's no
longer serving a purpose
it's no longer bringing them joy and
they don't want to put it in a storage
locker in perpetuity
and so what do they do with it and quite
often
the answer is well i guess i'll go to
goodwill or even worse i'll go to like
the gas station there's these little
bins where you can throw
clothes in there and we're not really
sure where it goes it's just this
this hole that we take our stuff to and
i can understand the concern because
it's not serving a purpose now but she
wants the stuff to maybe add value to
someone else's life
what do you recommend to people like
this i mean i know of a few resources
that i've recommended in the past but
i'd love to know what you think about
what people should do with their
unwanted stuff
well i have to say my new favorite thing
to do with myself my kids is to go
shopping at vintage clothing
stores and one of the best ways in in
kind of creating that um beautiful
array of choices is to consider
selling your your clothing that you
don't need anymore to companies like
real real
they'll give you the money for it and i
think that the money that i
i receive for most of my stuff i give it
back
to larger charities that then are able
to serve the population with
many things so it's almost like
sometimes that really special pair of
levi's jeans might be worth
way more money that you can make a
bigger impact with by donating it to the
charities that are out there to support
you know vulnerable families with the
clothing and the needs that they might
have
so i think there's a lot of value
sometimes in the items that we have held
on to for so long
that the the dollar amount might
actually do more good
and then you're supporting a whole new
industry that actually
i think is something that the future of
environmentalism is going to really be
uh digging into is that vintage clothing
second-hand shopping you know
don't buy new kind of thing so i love
that
yeah my wife and i there's a vintage
shop we went to an atwater village
maybe a couple years ago now and i was
just shocked by
some of the pricing that that these
items demand
and it's because it is something that is
vintage that someone wants of course
don't get caught up in the sunk cost
fallacy you may have paid a hundred
dollars for a dress that is
worth next to nothing now and it's
probably better to let it go
uh if you can't sell it you know my
personal rule is a 30-day rule if i'm
unable to sell something
now i like the the the the consignment
shop because real real
is is a consignment shop right some
things aren't that expensive there too
by the way
right right and what i found is that you
know
even if i'm selling a piece of furniture
or whatever quite often consignment
tends to be the best option because
you're outsourcing that to someone else
then if i were to just get on craigslist
or
ebay i know for the longest time if
anything was
i thought worth more than 20 dollars i
would try to sell it on ebay especially
when i was trying to get out of debt
because i wanted to to get the money
that i could from these resources i was
no longer using
so i could apply it to this debt and i
could experience some some freedom there
but by by letting go of the stuff
eventually i realized that a lot of the
things i
i couldn't sell at all and so um the
resource that i often use
if you're unable to sell it or if a
consignment shop won't take it there's a
website called donationtown.org i'm not
sure if you're familiar with them
but um it's a you just go to the website
and it will find
local charities some of the big ones of
course are going to be mentioned there
like goodwill
salvation army or whomever but uh i
found a lot of local charities where
i've been able to donate stuff even
things like mattresses
where you it's really hard to get rid of
a mattress usually but they'll
use them for for people who really need
a mattress or
your furniture or different appliances
even clothes you can go to
donationtown.org you can even find
places that will
that'll pick up a larger items
from from your house depending on what
area you're in you can do a sort of zip
code search there
and i think that'll that'll help you out
a lot rachel one more thing i can also
add is
a lot of the schools that we've served
in the past the
families there there are many families
who are homeless actually and if they're
under this title one kind of bracket
many of the families are living under
the poverty line so the principles
of those schools tend to accept things
so in your local area
at crayoncollection.org we actually have
a school finder where you just enter the
zip code and you can go in and find
either a head start school or a title
one school
and you can contact them and they will
most of the time take almost everything
that you've got
um it's there's so much need out there
it's unbelievable
but if yeah like like you said if the
good stuff gets sold take the money and
donate it to the charities that can then
do more with it but if you can't sell it
and it's something that you know you can
donate locally i highly recommend
checking out your title when schools
nearby
when my mother passed it was my first
foray into minimalism
and uh a lot of her things i knew i
couldn't sell
it they weren't worth anything and so i
was able to donate those to friends and
family locally
but there were a few things i was able
to sell and i took that money and gave
it to the two charities to help mom
through her her chemo and radiation
treatments and so
you know paying it back or paying it
forward in a way to to help other people
in need yeah i think that's really
important in the school thing it's it's
a need we don't even think about
you know but of course it would make
sense that they have the means to
redistribute there
and to people who are actually in need
so it's not just going somewhere that's
going to be stored in a warehouse
forever rachel i'm going to send you a
copy of our book essential it's an essay
collection and it really talks about
being intentional
one of the essays in there is about
clothing it's called the favorite
clothes of a minimalist
but it really talks about being
intentional with the things we bring
into our life because then we have fewer
things we have to try to sell or let go
and
in the future if we're really
intentional about with what we bring
into our lives so we'll send you a copy
of essential if you want the e-book or
the audiobook version those are the most
sustainable versions
i think you would argue um then we'll be
happy to send those to you also if you
want the print book
we're happy to send that to you as well
rachel thanks for your question
carolyn in toledo has a question one
issue i'm having
is receiving physical junk mail and i'm
hoping for some suggestions
i'd rather prevent the junk mail from
coming but i also don't think i should
waste
my precious time emailing and calling
companies to ask to be removed from
their lists
over and over again so i'm kind of at a
loss here
here's what i've already tried i went to
my local post office and spoke with a
person who
basically put off my request not to
receive the flyers
or items request addressed to quote
current
resident i reasserted myself saying that
i wanted
to register a request in writing and was
told that the conversation that we were
having was all that could be done
that i was registering a complaint
simply by talking to him
even though he didn't even know my name
and wouldn't take my name or address
he basically indicated that the post
office gets paid to shuffle around
junk so i get the impression that they
will not stop
so i've taken to writing the words
refused return to sender
on junk mail and putting it back in my
outbox we'll see how it goes
so my question at this point is twofold
one how do you prevent junk mail from
arriving and two
if it does arrive how do you handle it
so sheila i've done some things rather
aggressively on this front i'm not sure
what you've done i'd love to hear about
it but talk about wasteful
we get so much junk man i know whenever
i move especially
it's like the mailboxes are just teaming
with a bunch of things that
no one ever really asked for but it is
probably the thing
that strangely keeps the post office
operating i don't know what percentage
but it's probably upwards of 90 percent
of their volume
is what you and i would perceive as junk
mail either credit card offerings
catalogs we never wanted yeah direct
mailers etc
so let's let's talk about this because
she has two questions here how do you
prevent it
and then how do you handle it if it does
show up what do you do in your life well
there's a website and i have to
give you the website name i think i
probably have it here okay it's from our
website if you go to the minimalist.com
day 15 uh we'll probably talk about the
same thing but this is
the direct marketing association
dmacc.org
but they stop the catalogs and the junk
mail i won't say immediately but it's
they stopped
85 to 90 90 of it pretty quickly
good yes so that was going to be my
first suggestion is to
get in there and um communicate but the
other thing is like
for a period of time i was getting like
a almost like a yellow pages size book
from restoration hardware
and i never asked for that and i kept on
asking just like you know this person
just called in saying like it's my
it's my life that i'm spending my time
calling and saying please don't send me
this
but believe it or not if you take a
picture of that and post it on social
media and tag
the company and say i don't want this
anymore or this is so wasteful
pass it on i think that they are they're
listening out there those big
companies do not want that kind of
exposure but we need to also
communicate with the end user like us
appreciates or doesn't
and really make it clear and i think
that if enough people were to start
doing that they're going to have to
start thinking differently
i don't receive the restoration hardware
book anymore so i think that that worked
but right by the way they don't want to
send it to you if you absolutely don't
want it anyway they cost them a lot of
money to be able to send that big thick
book if you hate it and they know it's
just going to be a piece of trash not
only they have to pay to print the thing
they have to pay to ship it to you and
if it's creating a poor customer
experience they don't want to do that
i totally believe in consumers like us
speaking up because in all in all
honesty we
are the ones that have the power it's
just that many of us forget that we
actually have the power
yeah well carol i'm going to give you
one other website here it's
optoutprescreen.com that prevents the
major credit card bureaus
from sending you uh solicitations
basically
so both of these websites i believe they
require some identity verification last
time i did it so
you can't just go on there and you have
to prove that you are you so you can opt
out from these catalogs and these junk
mail offers
it doesn't eliminate 100 but the second
part of her question is how do you
handle it when they show up well i use
an app for this it's called paper karma
and it has been great and i think it
costs maybe 99 cents a month but
it's like the best dollar i spend a
month so anytime i do get junk mail
which is
less much less than it was before
because of dma choice.org and
optoutprescreen.com anytime i get junk
mail
i just open the app i take a photo of it
i don't even have to do anything
i take a photo hit enter and it
automatically unsubscribes me from that
piece of paper
and that company no longer sends me
stuff so i'm not getting stuff from
capital one i'm not getting the
current resident things anymore it's
been really helpful so paper karma
i would encourage you to check that out
and uh for your question thank you so
much carolyn i'm gonna send you a copy
of my favorite book of ours it's called
everything that remains it's a memoir
about when ryan and i first embraced
minimalism the five year journey from
being these suit and tie corporate guys
to becoming the minimalist it's my
favorite thing we've ever done
if you like our podcast i think you'll
really like the audiobook version
of everything that remains or if you
want we'll send you the ebook or the
book book version
of that book monica in redlands
california has a question for us
i work in tv production and we're
always having new technology coming in
so i'm always having this
old technology that has cost us
thousands of dollars
but i don't know what to do with it um i
have old wires all the usbs i
have a whole storage area so i would
love to know how do i
bring my minimalist lifestyle to my
workplace i'm a head of a department
and i don't know what to do with all
this old junk
yeah it's old technology no one uses it
but we spent thousands of dollars on it
it's hard to just donate it or
do like an e-waste donation so monica's
question here is
a little bit we touched upon the funk
the sunk the sunk cost fallacy
um a moment ago and yes maybe some of
this
tv equipment cost thousands of dollars
before but
the iphone one cost you a thousand
dollars a decade ago and it's worth
functionally nothing now right but it
doesn't mean
that we should be irresponsible with the
things that we're we want to get rid of
is there something you recommend
specifically to people who have
electronics that they
you don't want to just throw them in the
trash obviously the first thing that
comes to my mind is my son actually and
he is
um 10 years old and he is just
dying to expose himself to any
electronics that he can and he wants to
open everything up and learn about it
and take it apart
so because of kovid we've we've been
able to get this really great
computer i'm sorry not computer science
um mechanical engineer
student from uc santa barbara who he
can't go to school now so he comes over
and they take stuff apart and they look
at it and they learn from it and they
build new things and
i really feel like there's a huge market
right there like a little business a
little side thing
where these kids can learn and go in and
basically take stuff apart and
students in high school and in college
and all these places
those those are kind of like gems for
them you know those older things and
i just think it's such a learning
opportunity right there these kids go
nuts for it and what they're creating
out of these older pieces
is just mind-blowing yeah i remember
that age in particular
somewhere around 9 10 11 like i just
wanted to take things
apart and and there's there's something
innate that we want to like uh dive into
the thing and so
there's a lot of opportunity there you
know at age 40 now it's not something
that i'm
as as keen on doing right but it's
something that
that i think is really fascinating to
kids now of course if
you have this stuff and you want to get
rid of it you can't find
someone somewhere to take it you don't
know where to take it i think the epa
has a good resource on this i'll put a
link to it in
the show notes sean i sent you the link
this morning but
they have basically a bunch of different
centers and places you can take
your different electronics and it lists
even by by brand so
i don't know what brand these are but
say you had a bunch of xerox copy
machines
it gives you instructions on where you
how you can contact xerox or different
places that
that xerox machines would be taken and
you can figure that out locally so
i think if you have electronics and and
obviously we don't just want to throw
them away
um if you can find a place that that
recycles batteries you know i know like
local best buys and things like that
recycle batteries the building we're in
actually recycles batteries so anytime
i have extra batteries from home that we
end up using they
they recycle them here and yes it's much
less convenient than just throwing them
in the trash but it's a much
better thing to do don't throw them in
the trash yes exactly
so we'll put a link to that epa uh
epa.gov
site and in the show notes i think i
think you'll find some value in that
but other people will as well if you
have electronics that you want to donate
and monica also the other thing i'm
going to talk about here
since we're talking about electronics is
ryan and i have something called the
upgrade rule
or what you might call the don't upgrade
rule because one of the ways that we
create a bunch of electronic waste is
what we just we feel
the constant impulse the tug to always
buy the new
thing even if the old thing is still
working perfectly fine
and yes i know there's sort of planned
obsolescence in there but
even without that we see the commercial
we see the billboard and i
i must have the new iphone 13 or 14 or
whatever it is now
when my iphone 6 is working just fine
and so i'm going to send you a copy of
our minimalist
rule book it's 16 rules for living with
less one of those rules
is the don't upgrade rule we talk about
there are three options that you you can
do whenever you feel that
that impulse to to upgrade and by the
way that just came out as an audio book
as well the e-book is free if you go to
the minimalists.com
rule book or if you want the audiobook
you can find it there as well
all right i'm gonna move on to our
lightning round now sheila this is where
we answer
readers or listeners text messages they
text
their questions to 937-202-4654
and those texts go to both ryan's and my
phone and occasionally we answer them
just via text message we also uh
we also answer some questions here on
the podcast and we reply to as many
people as we can we obviously can't get
to everyone
but during the lightning round here's
what we try to do we try to answer
questions with a short shareable less
than 140 character response
but not really we can monitor on a bit
and we'll sean will tweeze out something
beautiful
and pithy that we can we can share on
social media if you like
carlos has a question for us what are my
recycling options
if i live in a city without a robust
recycling program
and some examples here las vegas where
carlos lives
missoula where i used to live missoula
montana they had a terrible recycling
program in fact i wondered if they were
just throwing it away and and calling it
recycling it was
they didn't recycle glass they hardly
recycled anything um
and so it was just difficult i guess the
the call because mizzou was so remote
the cost of recycling there it didn't
make sense financially for a for-profit
business
and i'm interested to hear what you have
to say on this because
um oh another place i live phillipsburg
montana which is
truly in the middle of nowhere you
basically had to take your own trash to
the trash dump there was no recycling
center anywhere
within a hundred miles of where i was
now that that is a a remote place well
let's take that off the table but for
smaller
places or even places like las vegas
that don't have a robust recycling
program
what do you recommend to people well
first of all why doesn't las vegas have
a robust recycling program that's my
question
yes that's what i'd like to know and i
think that that's where my mind goes is
like go to your city council meeting
start talking speak up
that should change right away las vegas
is not a small town in montana like you
just described so
there's really no reason for that if you
ask me yeah but that's just the way that
i think
immediately is that that change needs to
happen and the ball needs to start
rolling right there
yeah first and foremost secondly if
we're talking about plastics
unfortunately to me plastic recycling is
like
a big old farce it's not even happening
um we're at nine percent right now and
some say it's really three percent so
many times kind of stop you there when
you say we're at nine percent
is that nine percent of the say we take
a hundred
plastic bottles and put them in the
recycling only nine of them are being
recycled
correct why is that just because there's
um like you said there's so much first
of all there's a million plastic bottles
being thrown away per minute
in america alone so that is a massive
massive quantity a and b um it's not
like cans and
and gla glassware that actually when you
recycle it it comes out just as good as
new
it degrades so much that it's just not
worth it so
uh many times people feel this like uh
sense of kind of like comfort i'm gonna
drink this drink in my plastic water
bottle i'll put it in the recycling bin
and it'll get recycled but it's not
it's actually not so we we really don't
believe in recycling uh plastic at
habits of waste we believe
in refusing plastic all together um
we just don't think that it's even worth
attempting
to recycle plastic so it's not gonna
uh you know you're not gonna make change
unless you just refuse it
and that's not even talking about the
clam shells and cutlery and all that
stuff that's
definitely not going to get recycled
yeah let's talk about that so so with
the straws in particular
that was the thing that was near and
dear to your heart obviously it's a
piece of plastic
you're not anti-straw you're
anti-plastic straw
you can have metal straws and and you're
totally fine with that
um i assume uh but but there are
there are options for us we're allowed
to say no to some of these things
i think again this is something we don't
think about upfront
we're able to say you know what no i'm
not i'm not going to accept that
i'm going to say no to it and by the way
if the business that you're you're
buying from
refuses you then you can refuse to do
business with them
we get to vote with our with our wallets
that's right and i really think the
mindset shift is right there
it's like instead of thinking of so much
about recycling how can we stop it from
the beginning how can we just
you know turn off the tap in and not
even have this problem
is is my goal really yeah well that
actually that
dovetails perfectly into my pithy answer
here the most sustainable purchase is
the one that's left on the shelf
i think quite often we don't think about
that it's like well do i do i get
the this plastic thing or this plastic
thing which
which one's better for the environment
neither yeah right exactly
and what can i do now of course there
are
things now you may have plastic in your
home and
it's unfortunate you have a bunch of
plastic maybe you want to get rid of and
it's one of the reasons that i really
dislike places like the container store
for example because it does two things
really wrong i think it's one is
i don't i think organizing is just
well-planned hoarding so it doesn't
actually deal with the problem of
consumerism and over-indulgent
consumption
but second it creates all this
additional waste plastic
waste as well and so it's this this
i get it i understand the need to want
to be organized but that's probably not
the best route to take the best way to
organize your stuff
is to is to let go of most of it and the
best way to let go is of course not to
bring it in
in the first place see these beautiful
pantries on instagram of like different
snacks and this and
it's literally a glorific glorification
of plastic
you know all that packaging all those
plastic bins like let's rewind and just
get back to like the core problem why
are we buying
all those pre-packaged individual snacks
a to put in a plastic container b
you know let's like again let's start
from the beginning can we do things
differently
all together and so so how do we do
things differently what are some of the
old alternatives when
instead of saying well of course it's
gonna be really difficult to get to get
to zero plastic you're not advocating an
all or nothing strategy it's about a
radical reduction in the amount of
plastic we let in but how do we do that
what are the alternatives buy in bulk
number one you know rather than buying
individual packaged bags of chips for
your kids
lunches maybe i understand we're all
human beings we love those goodies
get one big one and then use reusable
containers to
divvy it up you get so much less waste
that way
that's just one example another one is
it's really fun to try and make recipes
like your own granola your own
bars your own fruit leathers there's a
lot of opportunities right now
especially since many people are still
at home
to create recipes that are just fun to
do with your kids and you just
create them with so much less waste yeah
yeah
i'm thinking about our home and we we
have some you know glass containers
reusable
i think the key to the reusables is
actually reusing them
because uh sometimes good intentions are
i'm gonna buy these reusable things
but it's actually worse for the
environment if you buy something and
then you just
don't reuse it you end up throwing it
away or discarding it relatively quickly
can you talk about that some jars like
you said i buy like pickle jars or some
different pickles or
whatever it is like a glass jar and
those are my to-go containers so i leave
them in my car
if i'm going to a restaurant and i'll
take them in and i'll refill them with
the food that i would have
otherwise asked for a to-go box and it's
going to be either polystyrene or
plastic or even aluminum with a plastic
lid or if i have leftovers at home and i
want to pass it out to like friends and
family i fill those up and i pass it out
like
that and they can continue living just
you know
constantly i might make a green juice at
home and fill those jars up with with
the juice
so it it is so beautiful to go and buy
these amazing bottles and this and that
you don't really need to your my water
bottle is a tomato sauce
jar actually and it's a beautiful bottle
it's a company called muti and i tagged
them and i was like you know these can
be really great water bottles afterwards
so they
start reposting and you know who said a
water bottle needs to be
branded to you as a water bottle yeah by
the way just thinking about that term
branding
you know it's i think of branding as a
pejorative i don't want to wear a bunch
of logos on my clothes it's
free average i paid someone for the
privilege of advertising on my body
or aren't we doing the same thing with
these fancy sports bottles or whatever
and in a weird way we're trying to
indicate something about
ourselves who we are as a person through
this this brand but of course that
we can never accomplish that i think the
last thing i want to
to touch on with carlos's question here
is i think
it it may even seem overly simplistic to
say but the less we
consume the less waste we produce
and and i want to think about that
because as a minimalist
environmentalism was not a the
the primary objective for me when we
first started simplifying
but it was this beautiful byproduct of
consuming
less stuff there was less packaging less
waste less things to donate or throw
away or try to sell
it was and it was maybe the
the best unintended benefit of living
with less
i mean to be really honest with you my
goal is to
do what you guys do and and empty my
house of all the stuff that i've
accumulated over the years
but i started to buy less from you know
maybe a few years back
but i still can't figure out like what
to do with a lot of the stuff so i find
myself finding solutions as i go and
that's how i reduce
what i have in in my you know possession
now but the goal is to get to the place
where you're at already so good for you
all right before we get into our
listener tips and our added value
segment today
it looks like we got a bunch more
surprise questions this week like
do paper straws really help are solar
panels bad for the environment
is there a checklist for greener
living plus we've got questions about
digital waste we've got questions about
food waste
we've got questions about regulation
versus personal responsibility
and environmentally friendly brands and
clothing
and composting and a million more
questions about
waste for sheila and if you want to hear
all that subscribe to our
maximal episodes on the minimalist
private podcast it's a completely
separate podcast
and it's the most honest way for the
minimalists to earn an income because
we don't believe in advertisements by
the way if you're not
a private podcast subscriber you're
literally missing
two-thirds of our show let me talk to
you about this for a second
i know that money can be tight right now
but we spend
exorbitant amounts of money on on random
things we waste
our money on things that don't give us
commiserate value
we'll spend three bucks for a cup of
coffee we'll spend
10 bucks on a meal that wasn't that good
it's just money here
money there everywhere we go
but we want to provide a value a service
to you that you're going to value it's
worth way more than the two dollars
that it costs it keeps this podcast 100
advertisement free
but it's really the second two thirds of
the show but it's also
a private podcast which means it's a
private space for ryan and i and our
guests we really work out a bunch of
different ideas
we're able to talk about things we don't
talk about in public
and if you haven't tried it out i'll
just say this you're missing out try it
out for a week try it out for
a month listen to our private podcast
theminimalists.com
support that way you can get a
personal link if you subscribe it'll
play in your favorite podcast app so if
you listen on
apple podcasts or on overcast or feedly
or any of these other places where you
listen to podcasts you get a personal
link so that our private podcast plays
in your in your favorite podcast app and
by the way these are
longer episodes they're deeper dives and
it just gives us the private space that
we need to mess up
without doing so in public i think
you'll enjoy these conversations a lot
by the way i would encourage you to
start with when you subscribe we give
you our
our 12 most popular episodes there a
list of those
but there was one recently that i really
enjoyed it was called
yes is more and i would encourage you to
check out that episode that's a great
place to start it was just me and ryan
but man that conversation flowed
the patreon comments on that were
phenomenal oh by the way
you also get access to our entire
patreon
community there where you interact with
over 5 000
other supporters of the podcast you get
to answer questions you get to talk to
each other
we interact with you there that is the
main place where ryan and i interact
with other people yes you can text us or
tweet us or whatever
and we get back to some of you when you
do that but
on patreon we respond to everyone
because
this is our core audience these are the
people that
really support what we do they get what
we do they give us the space
that we need to produce this podcast and
make it meaningful for others
and i wish you could hear some of these
patreon episodes these private podcast
episodes and you can it's just a couple
bucks
and you'll get way more than your two
dollars worth
so thank you so much if you are a
patreon supporter we appreciate it if
you want to become a supporter
the minimalists.com support all right
here are some voicemail comments and
tips from our listeners
hi this is molly from salt lake city i'm
calling
the tip regarding managing the
collecting
impulse one strategy i have used is to
make friends with
people who share the same hobby or
collection
and do regular exchanges with them so
you get the thrill of having a new item
but then when the thrill wears off you
just return it to the
other owner and you can get another new
item when you give it back
hi this is tara from seattle and i was
just calling
um in reference to molly when she was
talking about her trophies
uh one cool thing that i did was i took
all the little name plates
off and i kept them all like in a
scrapbook
you could do that or you could even put
them in a shadow box with your medals
or just set them up and take a really
cool picture and then keep that
otherwise check the trophies and you
know just enjoy the memories
but let them go all right joe thanks
again to sheila for joining us today i
encourage you to check out her
organization
it is called habits of waste
you can find it at habitsofwaste.org
also the crayon collection
crayoncollection.org check that out she
talked about that at the top
of the episode follow them on social
media
how changes on instagram
twitter and facebook how changes so
habits of waste how changes on all the
social media platforms
for our added value segment this week
there's a new single by our friend
canyon city it is a phenomenal song
it is called wish list i think we're
going to end this episode with it
with his permission although if you're
watching on youtube you'll probably hear
every little thing but
we'll put a maybe we can put a link to
it in the show description jordan
this new song is called wishlist the
reason i thought of it for this episode
is he filmed it it's a beautiful video
so if you get a chance check out the
video on
youtube we'll put a link to that in the
show notes but
speaking of environmentalism or lack of
waste
he filmed this in one of the most
beautiful places in
america in colorado and it's stunning
it looks like an environmentalist's
dream he's just out there
in the middle of the forest playing his
guitar with babbling brooks and
giant pine trees and it's a beautiful
video for a
beautiful song so i hope you enjoyed
that canyon city's new
single wish list which i believe is part
of an ep that will be coming out
later this year and real quick for right
here right now here's one thing that's
going on in the life of
the minimalist so i want to give you a
free ebook it's called 11 ways
to write better now we are all writers
now
you might write corporate emails you
might want to write a book
you might write tweets or text messages
but we are all writers maybe you're
aspiring to do something better
with that writing i want to give you 11
tips for free it's over on my website
howtowritebetter.org
that will also take you to the class
that i i teach
two or three times a year called how to
write better
it's closed right now we usually accept
about 100 students at a time currently
going through a class
right now but when that opens back up if
you're interested you can get on the
email list but
if not you can still get the free ebook
it's 11 ways to write better
i want to show you how to write better
better whether it's your texts
or blog posts or you want to write the
great american novel
or you just want to improve your
business emails i believe the rising
tide lifts
all boats and i'll show you how to write
better over how to write
howtowritebetter.org
you can follow the minimalists on
facebook twitter and instagram at the
minimalists
come see one of our live podcast shows
visit theminimalists.com
tour to find a city near you if you have
a question comment or minimalism tip for
our podcast
email a voice memo to podcast at
theminimalists.com
you can comment on this episode at
youtube.com slash the minimalists
and if you want our show notes in your
inbox sign up for our email list over at
theminimalists.com you'll also receive
our simple
sunday emails each week by the way if
you want to get our monday morning
minimal maxims texted right to your
phone
send us a text 937-202-4654
just text an emoji of the thing you got
rid of
most recently or just text a smiley face
there we'll add you to our monday
morning
minimal maxims each week we start your
week off with a bit of
simplicity never any spam never any junk
never any advertisements obviously but
uh if you leave here today with just one
message
we hope it's this love people
and use things because the opposite
never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh i bet that you'd be fine
without it